ahora vamos a hablar de la escala de
decibeles que es la escala que nos ayuda
a determinar qué tan fuerte o ruidoso es
un sonido y su fórmula luce así
es beta igual a 10 por el logaritmo base
de iu
entre 10 a la menos 12 watts por metro
cuadrado y esto luce intimidante pero no
lo es tanto ahorita vamos a ir
analizando lo poco a poco beta es el
número de decibeles número de decibeles
de cibeles
y esto lo habrá veamos con una d
minúscula y una b mayúscula de b y
seguramente han visto esto en sus
bocinas o en cualquier lugar en donde se
involucre volumen de sonido ya que el
volumen se mide en decibeles estévez
denota el hecho de que aquí tenemos de
sy vélez es la escala de decibeles y no
la escala de ver si le quitamos este 10
tendremos la escala de bell pero con
este 10 es la escala de decibeles del
logaritmo vamos a hablar en un momento y
la iv se refiere a la intensidad del
sonido
intensidad
la intensidad de la onda y en física
definimos la intensidad como la potencia
la potencia entre el área
potencia / área esto qué quiere decir
bueno imagínense que por aquí está su
oído
y de este lado nos están llegando ondas
de sonido
ahora la potencia está medida en watts y
el área en metros cuadrados vamos a
tratar de visualizar la intensidad de
esta onda supongamos que aquí tenemos un
metro cuadrado es un metro cuadrado que
está en el aire es un metro cuadrado de
área la potencia que atraviesa esta área
va a ser cuántos jules pasan a través de
este metro cuadrado
cuántos dulces energía por segundo pasan
a través de este metro cuadrado este es
el número de watts por metro cuadrado
que pasan aquí y esta es nuestra
intensidad esto nos da una idea de
cuánta energía de sonido está pasando
por cierta unidad de área y esta parte
de la ecuación es mi favorita este
número de 10 a la menos 12 watts por
metro cuadrado esto representa el límite
del oído humano
es decir es el sonido más suave que
podemos percibir el oído humano
cualquier sonido con una intensidad
menor a esta nosotros no lo vamos a
notar y cualquier sonido que tenga esta
intensidad o un poquito más arriba
cualquier oído humano sano lo va a poder
escuchar y la razón por la que me gusta
tanto este número es porque es
tremendamente pequeño
esta es una billonésima parte de un wat
por metro cuadrado y esto qué significa
bueno significa que aunque sea una
billonésima parte de un you'll por
segundo pase a través de este metro
cuadrado nuestro oído podrá detectar ese
sonido aunque sea tan suave y si esto no
nos impresiona veámoslo de esta otra
manera
imaginemos que aquí tenemos un watt
y uruguay no es mucha potencia que
digamos
si tenemos un wat que tan grande puede
ser el área en la que podrá extenderse y
seguir siendo lo suficientemente intenso
como para que el oído humano pueda
escucharlo
será del tamaño de un campo de fútbol o
del tamaño de una ciudad no
resulta que si ustedes hacen los
cálculos lo cual les recomiendo que
hagan van a tener que podemos repartir
un watt en toda el área de terreno que
pertenece a alemania
a veces tres veces y aún así poder
escuchar su sonido así de sensible es el
oído humano sinceramente esto es
increíble y ya se los había comentado y
regresando a esto lo único que nos falta
es ver qué pasa con esto
con este logaritmo porque los físicos
tuvieron que usar logaritmo aquí esto
como que intimida bueno ahorita les voy
a explicar por qué se usa resulta que ya
que nuestro oído puede escuchar sonidos
con una intensidad tan baja 10 a la
menos 12 watts por metro cuadrado quiero
decir que hay un rango enorme del sonido
que podemos escuchar es decir nosotros
podemos escuchar desde 10 a la menos 12
watts por metro cuadrado
que es cero puntos 0 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 y 11 aquí what's por metro cuadrado
hasta pues no hay un límite superior
pero ya que llegamos a un watt por metro
al cuadrado
aquí ya empieza a ser doloroso el sonido
ya no nos gusta escuchar algo tan
intenso a partir de este punto ya nos
van a estar doliendo los oídos y este es
un rango enorme de 12 órdenes de
magnitud este wat por metro cuadrado es
un billón de veces más que esto y como
es una escala tan grande vamos a querer
cambiar a una escala más manejable no
queremos rangos de 1 a un billón o una
billonésima parte y es por eso que
usamos los logaritmos los logaritmos son
muy buenos para esto y es por eso que a
los físicos les gusta este truco el
logaritmo puede tomar números muy
grandes o muy pequeños y volver los
números con los que nos guste trabajar
y esto es lo que significa vamos a
recordar que es un logaritmo en caso de
que aún no lo recuerden
logaritmo base 10 de un número va a ser
igual voy a poner un número aquí vamos a
decir que quiera hay 100.000
y con el logaritmo base 10 siempre nos
preguntamos cuánto tengo que elevar este
10 para obtener el número que está aquí
así que el logaritmo se fija en el
número que está aquí en este paréntesis
y se pregunta a qué número tengo que
elevar este 10 para obtener este número
bueno nosotros conocemos la respuesta la
respuesta es 10 a las 5 si elevamos 10 a
las 5 vamos a tener 100.000 tengo que
elevarlo a las 5 para obtener este
número y si este es el número que use
entonces esta es la respuesta a mi
logaritmo mi logaritmo base de 10 de
100.000 es 5 y ahora vean lo que pasó el
logaritmo tomó un número muy grande y lo
transformó en un número pequeño es a
esto a lo que me refiero cuando digo que
el logaritmo puede tomar números muy
grandes o muy pequeños y volver los
números con los que es agradable
trabajar
por ejemplo el logaritmo base 10 d
mil millones mil millones es un número
enorme va a ser igual
recordemos que el logaritmo se pregunta
a qué número tengo que elevar este 10
para que me dé este número de entre los
paréntesis y para que nos dé mil
millones
tenemos que elevarlo a la 9 ya que
tenemos uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis
siete ocho nueve ceros
así que si mi respuesta el logaritmo es
que tengo que elevar este 10 a la 9 para
obtener este número entonces la
respuesta o el resultado de mi logaritmo
9 y es por esto que los logaritmos son
buenos el logaritmo toma un número tan
grande como 1000 millones y lo
transforma en un 9 y es por eso que
usamos este logaritmo en nuestra fórmula
para manejar las escalas ya que toma
escalas enormes o escalas muy pequeñas y
las transforma en escalas fáciles de
manejar vamos a hacer un pequeño ejemplo
usando esta fórmula imaginémonos que
ustedes están hablando con un amigo y
más que hablar le están gritando tienen
una discusión algo apasionada entonces
ustedes están gritando aquí vanas ondas
de sonido y aquí está su amigo a quien
le están gritando
y digamos que ustedes están gritando con
una intensidad de 10 a la menos 5 watts
por metro cuadrado que podría no
aparecer mucho pero realmente sí es
bastante ustedes están bastante enojados
y seguramente su amigo no está muy
contento yo lo que quiero saber es
cuántos decibeles equivalen esta
intensidad a cuántos decibeles equivale
esto bueno pues vamos a usar la fórmula
de los decibeles el número de decibeles
es igual a 10 por el logaritmo base 10
de la intensidad
/ y eso siempre va a ser constante 10 a
la menos 12 watts por metro cuadrado que
es la intensidad más leve que nuestro
oído puede distinguir que voy a usar
aquí
bueno este 10 a la menos 5 es mi
intensidad que la voy a poner aquí así
que voy a tener que beta es igual a 10
por el logaritmo base 10 de la
intensidad que es 10 a la menos 5 entre
10 a la menos 12
ambos tienen unidades de watts por metro
cuadrado los cuales se van a cancelar
y cuánto es 10 a la menos 5 entre 10 a
la menos 12 pues resulta que es 10 a las
7 así que esto es igual a 10 por el
logaritmo base 10 de 10 a las 7
bueno el logaritmo no me gusta pero ya
sé cómo manejarlo el logaritmo se
pregunta a cuánto tengo que elevar este
10 para que me dé el número que está
aquí entre paréntesis
bueno el número al que tengo que elevar
el 10 para obtener lo que está en este
paréntesis es el 7 aquí ya tengo un 10 a
las 7 está en la misma forma así que
tengo que elevar este 10 a las 7 para
obtener el 10 a las 7 así que el
logaritmo de 10 a las 7 y 7 por lo que
el número de decibeles que voy a tener
es 10 por el logaritmo de 10 a las 7 que
7 10 por 7 es igual a 70 decibeles y
aquí no me caben las unidades así que lo
escribo aquí son 70 decibeles le estamos
gritando a nuestro amigo y seguramente
se va a enojar con nosotros y es de esta
manera
de esta manera como calculamos el número
de decibeles